bueno en principio como bien decía la
contaminación que ha quedado en el medio
ambiente que va a tener una extensión de
20 mil años y sobre todo lo que tiene
que ver con la industria nuclear no esto
de acuerdo a las cifras que se manejan
no solamente los muertos que hubo en ese
momento que fueron reconocidos
oficialmente como 31 sino entre las
cifras más este que tenemos hoy más más
actuales hablan de entre 2.000 y 1.000
personas con cáncer e incluso a
greenpeace está dando estas cifras que
llegan a 200 mil personas que murieron
de cáncer y que se activan en 100 mil
más no es lo que tenemos en el medio
ambiente en la zona de exclusión
de chernóbil que son este prácticamente
30 30 kilómetros a la redonda que están
inhabitables no sí ahora profesor
algunos adultos mayores han regresado a
sus hogares en polio cercanos a
chernóbil argumentando que lo único que
querían era morir en su casa pero
realmente se puede regresar
para efectivamente hay gente que se
resistió a irse hay incluso indicios de
vida natural que está emergiendo sin
embargo eso es una zona que sigue
estando esté contaminada a pesar de que
incluso se organizan de tours de turismo
para visitar la zona y lo recomendable
lo que recomiendan los expertos es no
estar en la zona porque sigue siendo
todavía muy peligroso claro ahora por
último porque la tragedia de chernóbil
aceleró la desintegración de la unión
soviética bueno en verdad las reformas
se venían dando desde antes este ya con
el secretario general andrópov se
iniciará una serie de reformas en unión
soviética en todo caso lo que hizo este
accidente fue acelerar ese proceso
se reforzó con la llegada de mijail
gorbachov al secretariado general en lo
que se conoce como perestroika y glasgow
lo que apuntó un proceso de reforma de
la unión soviética en parte por los
problemas que condensó un accidente como
como el de chernóbil que tenía que ver
sobre todo con cuestiones de económicas
respecto a la eficiencia de ese sistema
y que terminó en un objetivo no deseado
al menos en principio que fue la
disolución de la unión soviética
profesor gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros aquí en france 24 que tengo
feliz resto de días